so I'm getting this out a little later
than I generally like to with new doctor
who reviews but sorry I know I was
supposed to be scared to go to sleep
after the end of this thing but I was
beat I went right to bed with no
reservations sleep no more quick
reminder I don't do spoiler free anymore
although before I get into spoilers I
will say not a great episode now going
into this thing right off the back I was
nervous because it's got the whole first
person thing going on which is well
first of all I hate first person in film
but this thing overcomes the inherent
issues with first-person camera
perspective in movies because in movies
it's always just one jerk with a camera
who just won't put it down you're like
why are you filming that why is this
going this much better put together this
is right from the beginning we're told
look I've assembled this existing
footage to show you what has happened
this was the best I could do amongst
other things that allows us to jump
perspectives we're seeing it through
this person's eyes now we're seeing it
through that person's eyes and nobody is
physically carrying a camera so it get
killed the major problems that I usually
have with this kind of genre that said
it's still very gimmicky now that's not
inherently a problem doctor who can't be
very gimmicky blink is incredibly
gimmicky midnite's very gimmicky that's
not to say it always works cuz Love &
Monsters is pretty gimmicky too the odd
thing about this one is this episode
doesn't work but it's not because of the
gimmick the gimmick works fine all
things said and done it doesn't really
detract and actually Kay made the
presentation slightly more interesting
it didn't make me motion sick which can
be a problem for me with these sorts of
things sometimes and the aesthetics kind
of cool it's very aliens the sort of the
opening segments of aliens where it's
the Marines going into the base you know
before they find the hive and all that
and I think it's very intentional I mean
the outfits they've got these guys in
there are sort of reminiscent of that
with the helmets and the rifles and just
the whole vibe of the thing so I mean I
like that they're pulling that I think
it works pretty well but just what this
story actually is I don't know what this
thing is I gotta be honest mostly I'm
just gonna rip on the monsters from here
on out now I
a little bit bad doing it because I I'm
not sure if I entirely understand
exactly what they were supposed to be
and regardless of whether I understand
it fully or not the explanations and the
comparisons and the analogies given for
what they are make them really laughable
oh that stuff do you clear around the
corner I will your wake up it's that
like really so there's a fall down on
concept right there but beyond that just
the look of the things isn't great I
mean the the face was sort of a lack of
a face and it's this big gaping thing is
okay but you pull back and look at the
whole thing the sort of textural nature
of it it didn't just looks like foam and
the way they move isn't terrific
there is one shot where it's sort of
them coming through the flames and and
the way that's lit in the way the shot
is kind of mangled they actually look
cool and creepy in that shot but that's
the only shot the rest of the time I'm
looking at him going and that was before
I even knew what they are when when the
hand first came through and they closed
the door on it's like I'm looking at
that hand going that does not look scary
to me that looks dumb there were just
various moments sort of played like they
were supposed to be twists or reveals
like that that the guy was so the guy
who invented the Morpheus machine was
still alive and well and none of it ever
felt like oh I didn't see that coming I
was like okay so that's what happened
next I don't know it was just really
hard for me to get invested in this one
and maybe it was just because so many
very laughable concepts were brought in
from the start but things though there
are moments that work really effectively
what a moment that I loved was when the
one guy was trying to get through the
door and the computer made him sing and
wouldn't let him through that actually
instantly made me wish I wish this was
an AI controlling computer gone mad
situation because with him trying to
negotiate with that door and I had this
tone as a voice that was like GLaDOS
from the portal games and you couldn't
quite tell if it was toying with him or
if it was just doing what it was
programmed to do and I really loved that
moment it immediately made me wish I
wish this computer was the villain
because this this moment is so much more
tense and interesting and fun then
pretty much the whole rest of the
episode well ultimately I'm not entirely
sure what it is that
that doesn't where I mean I I know
various components of this thing that
doesn't work I'm not very sure why it
doesn't work overall because dr. who can
overcome a goofy-looking monster dr. who
can overcome a goofy concept I mean the
thing that sort of comes to mind was
mummy on the Orient Express but I really
liked that episode but it's just
something in this one about the
combination of a goofy premise a goofy
look to the monster a gimmick that
doesn't hurt the thing but isn't really
adding a ton and a supporting cast that
is fine but unremarkable I think
ultimately that's that's why I couldn't
really grab on to this there's a bunch
of things that are either ok or not good
but there's no one element that I can
grab on and go oh there's the saving
grace that's what brings it up in
elevates it like to compare it again to
mummy on the Orient Express the
supporting cast of that episode was
wonderful and they elevated what could
have been a very goofy episode this this
episode unfortunately doesn't have that
saving grace to elevate it and prop up
the weaker elements and so it just ends
up being a weaker episode so I guess
that about wraps it up for me have you
seen Sleep No More if you have what were
your thoughts about a drum something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it until next time this council is
adjourned boom I tell you I'm really